the battle to control the coyote 19
pandemic in latin america
is underway but is being hindered by
patchy deliveries of the vaccine
and scandals in the government with the
task of organizing the vaccination
programs
the latest to go is the ecuadorian
health minister juan carlos
who admitted ensuring that his family
was given preferential treatment
we have all committed errors this is a
pandemic that has taught us the
importance of recognising them
last month as the vaccines arrived in
ecuador a country one of the highest per
capita death rates in the region
he said they would firstly be given to
the most vulnerable
for the people who are on the front line
medical staff and also people over 65
years old
many of them are still waiting for the
former minister
has fled the country a similar scandal
emerged earlier in peru
when it was revealed that at least two
ministers and a former president
were among nearly 500 people to be
immunized weeks before the rest of the
population
and in argentina a few days later their
health minister genes gonzalez garcia
resigned when it came to light he'd
invited friends and colleagues to
receive what have been called
vip vaccines his replacement carlo
vistotti has since tested positive for
kovite 19
and is self-isolating supplies from a
number of sources continue to arrive
this first batch of nearly 200 000 doses
landing in uruguay
from the chinese cinevac laboratory
and 40 tons of oxygen donated by chile
to peru
where supplies have run dangerously low
[Applause]
but protests against handling of the
pandemic are increasingly common this
one on saturday in buenos aires
if they give it to the president and the
vice president then okay
but they shouldn't vaccinate the
deputies or the ministers that's no good
i've got inside information from
independent media that the pandemic
doesn't exist
it's just tests that have fooled the
whole world
while they're angry with the government
some still believe the pandemics is a
hoax
while others are against the vaccine
whatever else people feel they're
impatient to put the pandemic behind
them
frustrated by the slow pace of the
vaccination programs
confused by contradictory information
and angered by corruption in their
governments
the road towards normality is still
fraught with obstacles
daniel schweiner al jazeera buenos aires